abone ol
e herkese merhaba ben Utku bu orta sınıf
bir öğretmen ailenin Ortalama bir çocuğu
olarak taşladı doğmuşum taşlı da büyüdüm
bu memeden kesilmesi gereken zamanda
Mehmet herkes silmişim konuşmaya
başlamam gereken zamanda konuşmaya
başlamıştım yürümeye başladım gereken
zamanda duyurmaya başlamışım her şey çok
normal her şey çok sıradan ortalamak en
her iki buçuk yaşında bundan 33 yıl
evler buna gerçekten 33 alevler
Çok konuşma
bu tekleşme başlamış bazı sesler
çıkaramadı olmuşum bir yürürken Tok
izlemeye başlamışım başlarda çok üzerine
düşmüşler Çünkü teyzem bizi ziyarete
gelmiş Yeni yılda yeni yalan bir hafta
önce bunlar gerçekten 33 yıl ev var ona
şımarıklık yaptığımı salmışlar başlarda
var ama bu bu tökezleme hale düşmeye
konuşamama durumu idin İyi ki hiç
konuşamaz hale gelmeye başlayınca bir
sorun olduğunu anlamışlar beni hastaneye
götürmüşler bir Hekim bakmış bu tahmin
ettiklerinden daha büyük bir problem
olduğunu
olabileceğini Bu yüzden de daha uzman
bir ekibin uzman bir hekimin batması
gerektiğini
söylemiş Ve beni üniversite hastanesine
sevk etmiş apar topar Üniversite
Hastanesinde gitmişiz
Ama bu bir problemin başlaması Ondan
sonra hastane Ondan sonra Versa
Hastanesi ve birkaç gün o birkaç gün
içerisinde artık iyice
konuşamaz yürüyemez Hatta boynumu
tutamaz olmuş çocuk sadece
bu şöyle bir Ah Ne var anlattıkları
benimle gözümde
en son söyleyebildim kelimeler dayı dayı
dayı dayı dayı mı zayıflamış daha uzakta
dayımı çağırmışlar
Bu on
the şöyle bir şey düşünün bir hastane
odası bir yatak yatakta iki buçuk
yaşında bir kız çocuğu bedeni Kapı
açılıyor bu birimi çeviremiyorum kafamı
çeviremiyorum dayımı görüyorum Dayı
diyemiyorum sadece Göz bebeklerimi
çevire biliyorum
Bir Damla Yaş bu kadar çok kısa bir süre
içerisinde bu hale gelmiş
Ama
bir gün iyice sen al aşmışım artık
hayatı tehlikeye doğru gitmeye başlamış
günün geç saatlerinde bir apar topar
operasyonu almışlar
operasyona giderken de hekimler demiş ki
çok da bütün Hala hastanede burada
kalmanıza gerek yok Eve gitseniz
dinlerseniz daha iyi olacak bu uzun
süren bir operasyon olabilir
bir masada kalabilir Bu yüzden de burada
kalmasını daha iyi olur şeklinde
konuşmuştu Tabii başlarda kabul etmemiş
E biraz annemi göndermek istemiştir
başlarda kabul etmemişler ama sonra yani
orada durumda bir anlamı olmadığını
düşünerek eve gitmişler eve gitmek
dinlenmek
uyumak anlamına gelmiyor Elbette telefon
başında beklemişler sabah beş sabah 5'e
kadar beklemişler
bu telefon çalıyor Alo değil Utku
yaşıyor diyorlar
Oh edin Bayramımız
var ama hekimler her zaman temkinli dir
biliyorsunuz yaşadığı Ama
yürüyemeyebilir
konuşmaya bilir demişler tekrar ediyorum
konuşmaya biliriz
mı burada minik adımlarla size kendi
hikayemi anlatıyorum Ve bunu çok heyecan
verici olduğunu düşünüyorum bana bunu
sağlayanlar Öncelikle
E tabi operasyona kalbin fizik tedavi
süresince
Öncelikle hekimler hemşireler sağlık
çalışanları sonra ailem Günler aylar
hatta Yıldız yıllar
Biz bunu sağlayan Öncelikle bilim
akabinde emek ve sabır
bu ve en nihayetinde ortalama hayatımı
geri dönüş
O benim annem Politik bir aile Biz de
akşam yemekleri ana var bir tane denk
gelir Biz politiko konuşuruz
o gün içerisinde haber kanalları sürekli
açık olursa o zamanlar Haber yayınları
Sende bir kulağımız orada
bu çünkü biz Kendimizden başka herkesin
acısını acımız yaptık
Ben dünyanın öbür ucunda bir insanın göz
yaşı bile içimizi parçalamaya yetti
ne mesela
Bu sadece No 7 için hayatını dört
yaşında kaybeden Saliha
Bu sadece na7 iç
bu orta böcek salon öldürmek için at onu
tarım ilaçları dediğimiz tarım
zehirlerin arka bulunan mırıl meyvesine
sızlıyor bütün aileyi zehirliyor
bu Saliha'nın minik bedeni Kaldıramadı
için hala kaybediyoruz
bu tarlayı tanımıyorum ve ki tanıyacağım
Ama onun haberi içimi parçaladı
ben Saliha Biz üretici
ailesinden gelmiyor tüketici ailesinden
geliyor hepinizin olduğu gibi
Evet tamam tüketici ailelerin çocukları
böyle üretici ailelerin çocukları nasıl
Buradan da bir örnek vereyim size hiç
güzel olmayan bir örnek ve değersiz
sofralar konferansında bir araştırma bu
içerisindeki Hekim anlatmıştı onun
çalışmasını sizinle paylaşacağım
biliyorsunuz haram pamuk üretimi yapılan
bir bölge ve pamuk En çok tarım zehri
kullanılan tarım ürünlerinden bir tanesi
bu Harran'da yapılan bir çalışmada
bu em pamuk sezonundan hemen evvel bahar
aylarında Orada
çalışan üreticiler tarım işçilerinin
sağlık kontrolleri yapılır taramaları
yapılıyor sonra pamuk sezonundan sonra
yaklaşık 3 ay sonra yine aynı kişilerin
sağlık taramaları yapılıyor Sadece üç ay
içerisinde gözle görülür bir hasar
tespit ediyorlar bedenlerinde bilhassa
solunum yollarında
Evet şimdi bu tarım işçileri yetişkin
bireyler orada çalışmayı kabul ettiler
diyelim bunu biliyorlardı diyelim Peki
Onların çocukları o tarım işçileri
bu üreticiler evlerini akşam
gittiklerinde sadece kıyafetleri ile
taşıdıkları tarım sehirleriyle e
çocuklarını zehirliyorlar hep birlikte
zehirli yoruz
Bak şimdi benim Yürüme ve konuşma mı
sağlayan kişilerin sağlık çalışanları
ailem bunların bir kısmını çocuğu var
Annemler bir kısmının çocuğu yok
biliyorum
Bu bir kısmının çocuğu var mı yok mu
bilmiyorum bildiğim tek bir şey var Bir
çocuğun yaşama hakkını savunmak için
çocuğumuz olmasına gerek yok
Dur bekle
bu tutku Sen ne yapıyorsun Bunun için
bir şey yapıyor musun an ortalama
hayatını yaşamaya devam ediyorum onu Bu
kez taşlı dikent zengin apartmanlar
arasında sıradan bir apartman dairesi
ve ekolojik besleniyorum yeraltı
Tohumdan tarım zehirsiz sene gübresiz
besleniyorum
o zehirsiz temizleniyor
ve temiz giyiniyorum yani Adil ve etik
üretimini üretilen giysileri gidiyorum
evinde birçok kovan yok
ve sosyal girişimciyim içerik üreticisi
bu ve çevre aktif değil
bu Evim de çok kalın olmaması Ben ilginç
yapan şey biliyorum evinde çok
kullanıyorum şu kapatacak bir şey yok
yani çok beni atılırdı hatırlamıyorum
Sen bana sürekli tüketmenin söyleyen
hızlı tüketim kültürünü Bence kültür
süzdüğünü kabul etmiyorum almadığım için
atmıyorum
Selam bugün kullandım bir karton
bardağın mikroplastiklerin Ben öldükten
çok sonra dahi gezegende kalacağını
biliyorum yalnız söylemedim Yanlış
duymadınız karton bardakta ki
mikroplastikler
bir tek kullanın petrokimya türü plastik
kullanmıyorum kullanmadığım için
atmıyorum kullan-at kullanma atma
Bu bir gıdanın ne kadar zor zahmet
üretildiğini biliyorum gıdanın her bir
zerresine kıymet veriyorum
mi Evet yeteri kadar alıyorum ihtiyacım
kadar doğru israfta etmiyorum doğru
bu ve birçok kişinin çöp olarak gördüğü
kabukları saplarındaki soframı dahil
ediyorum bu bizim kültürümüzde var bir
sübli iyi kavun çekirdeğinden yaparız
de atamadığım için de Çöp kovasını
ihtiyacın yoksa biraz miktarda kalın
organik atığın içinde atıyorum komposto
yapıyorum yani onları nitelikli bir
toprak haline getiriyor
abone ol
ve ekolojik besleniyorum Çünkü ben bir
mi arayacağım diye bir çocuğun
hazırlanmasını ölmesine kabul edemiyorum
ve ekolojik test ediyorum çünkü
sen bilirsin üretim yapmanın ne kadar
zor olduğunu biliyorum ve ureticiye şunu
demek istiyorum ben buradayım Sen yeter
ki üretmeye devam et ben varım
bu Ve bunu yaparken de eşime dostuma
herkese söylüyorum zehir Sizler zehirsiz
var zehir Sizler herkese söylüyorum Şu
markadaş larımız soruyorum iş
arkadaşlarıma söylüyor ilkokul
arkadaşlarımız soru iş arkadaşlarım
herkese söylüyor takipçilerime
söylüyorum sosyal medyadaki kurumlarda
verdiğim eğitimlerde söylüyorum bu
konuşmayı hazırlarken Konu komşu epeyce
anlatmış oldum ki istiyorum ki zehirsiz
var niye yazsınlar onları anlatayım hep
birlikte zayıf sizin almaya başlayalım
biz bu bahçedeki üretici Garanti verelim
sonra biraz daha büyüyelim diğer
bahçedeki üreticileri de garanti verelim
ve herkese hirsizlar üretmeye
başlasınlar çünkü istiyorum ki çocuklar
zehirlenmesi
ama Hiçbirimiz zehirlenme elim hiç bir
şey zehirlenmesi
3'ü ülkemizin bereketli toprakları
dediğimiz bu yalan var ya Aslı şöyle bir
ülkemizin hareketsiz tozları
bu ülke topraklarımızın yüzde seksen
8'inde sağlıklı bir toprakta bulunması
gereken Mikroorganizma miktarı yüzde
2'nin altında
Allah sizi tarım literatürünü Biz bunu
toprak değil toz diyor
ve Mikroorganizma ve bakteri gibi şeyler
Ne yaparlar bu topraktaki mineralleri
meyve verirler vitaminleri meyveyle ya
da bizim yapması sağlarlar
var yani fasulyenin hakettiği magazin
üzerinde tutabilmesi için o bakteri
ihtiyacımız var
bu aromasını yazıyoruz fasulyeden ne
kadar magnezyum var karşımıza çıkan O
rakam Eğer sağlıklı bir toprağımız yoksa
çok da doğru değil yani
O bizim kutudaki o fasulye tükettiğiniz
hak ettiğimiz magnezyumu
bu alabilmemiz için o bakteri
ihtiyacımız varsa bir fasulyenin
hakettiği magnezyum olabilmesi için tek
şarkımız Toprak mı hayır değil tohumda
Çünkü biz solundan vazgeçtik Biz ne
zaman ki atılık ve yerel tohumlarımızı
an vazgeçtik Bunun yerine kısır dediğim
gibi tohumları koyduk İşte o gün
kaybettik
bir tohum kaynaklı mineral ve vitamin
kayıpları en çok B vitamini ve demir de
rastlanmış B vitamini ve demir
hepimizin eksikliği olan şeyler
en son firmalarının aynı zamanda fenni
gübre ve aynı zamanda tarım zehirli ve
aynı zamanda gıda takviyesi satıyor
olması ilginç bir tesadüf
ama biz gıdamız incelikli üretemiyoruz
bu hak ettiğimiz mineral vitaminleri Biz
alamıyoruz üzerine zehirleniyoruz
bu orta böcek bakteri sürün yanar III
önüne gelir satarım zehirlerini onu
öldürüyoruz
bu aynı zamanda bize emanet edilen
toprakları toz haline getiriyoruz
elimizden kayıp gitmesine izin veriyoruz
bu idare Tan doymaktansa beslenebiliriz
ama yediğinizde sarılıp gezegeni
onarabiliriz
Bu Toprağın sağlıklı hale getirip iklim
krizini tersine çevirebiliriz ya onu
yeter şey çok basit
tüketim alışkanlıklarımızı minicik
değiştirmek Minicik minicik
ne mesela
mı bu hafta
en yeni yıl sofralarımız için meyve
sebze alacağız bu şehir Sizler
alabiliriz Nar berekettir güzel dediğin
sofralarını Bereket getirir
Bu bir Sizin var olurken tabi yanımızda
kiloda taşırsak iyi olur
bu Önümüzdeki hafta da zehirsiz var
alabiliriz Önümüzdeki hafta da zehir
Sizler alabiliriz yine yaparken eşimize
dostumuza herkes de bunu neden
yaptığımızı söyleyebiliriz Hatta belki
Birlikte alabiliriz alışveriş grubu
kurarım
Ya ben biliyorum ben zor şartlarda
yaşadığımız için Sizinde etrafınızda
zehirsiz ne alıcınız yerler olduğunu
biliyorum ama diyelim ki yok bunun için
ne yapabiliriz
eve giren yönetiminin kapısını çalarız
yerel üretim yerel yönetimimize üretici
pazarları istiyorum diyebiliriz ekolojik
pazarlar istiyorum organik pazarlar
istiyorum diyebiliriz bunun için varlar
Allah bir ayetinde kapısını çalmış ki an
mahallemde komposto alanları istiyorum
ederse çok güzel olur Çünkü organik
atıklarımızı de tekli bir toprak haline
getirirsek harika olur mahallede kompost
alanları Tabi sadece yerel yönetimler mi
Hayır devlet de devletimizden de
isteyebilecekler imiz var teşviklerini
desteklerini kendi tohumunu koruyan
üreticiye
oy vermelerini isteyebiliriz zehirsiz
Nar üreten üretici vermelerini
isteyebiliriz
var bunun için varlar
Bu bir kapısını çalmış kente komik
Plastikler yasaklansın aynı zamanda yeni
enerji kaynaklarını geçirsin edersek çok
güzel olur
bu yani çok yani çok denedik Biz Bizum
Utku sen geliyorken biz dönüyorduk
diyorsanız birde bunu deneyelim diyorum
çünkü
Evet bunu yapabiliriz biliyorum
ve bu hayatımın ikide bir şans olduğunun
farkındayım bana bunu veren Bunu
sağlayan yaşamımı konuşmamı yürümemizi
sağlayan
biz bu kişilere sağlık çalışanlarına
aileme ve aynı zamanda bana bu
toprakları emanet edenlere
borcum var Ben yolundayım
da buna eşlik eder misiniz herkes ve her
şey
abone ol